so Elijah Elijah Cummings unfortunately
died today and it's really I have to say
it's it's pathetic and sad to see what
the media has done with his death
Cummings had a long and storied career
but the media has eulogized him
primarily as a Trump critic or target of
Trump criticism as if that something
that only came up you know for Elijah
Cummings this this only the last couple
of years of his life had anything to do
with Trump at all and so but they've
decided that's going to define him as if
that's the most significant thing about
him so look at some of these headlines
from the Washington Post representative
Elijah Cummings Democratic leader and
regular Trump targets dies at 68 CNN
says representative Elijah Cummings key
figure and Trump investigations dies at
68 the independent says Elijah Cummings
death senior Democrat at center of Trump
and Pietschmann probe dies aged 68 this
is what their Trump obsession has
wrought they have they have minimized
him into Trump target figure and Trump
impeachment it all revolves around Trump
for these people everything revolves
around Trump even the even the the
obituary now of Elijah Cummings who had
been in public life for what 40 years
his last couple of years going to
head-to-head head-to-head with with
Donald Trump for the media that's all
that matters it all boils down to that
pretty pretty outrageous and sad to see
okay so what I want to start with today
on this show today we're gonna take a
step away from politics sort of and talk
about a few things a few interesting
things that obviously have political
implications because everything does but
are much deeper and more important I
think and we're gonna start with a
fascinating article written by somebody
who interviewed over 5,000 biologists
and asked them when does life begin and
there was a 96% consensus almost
unanimous 96 percent of the biologists
gave an answer
and the 96% agreed and we're gonna look
at what their answer is and what they
agreed on in just a minute but first a
word from ancestry DNA you know I think
it's it's it's it's a it's not just a
nice little bit of information or a bit
of trivia to know where you're from what
your ancestry is it is crucial to
understanding yourself understanding
your family where you come from you know
what you're all about it's just that's
what ancestry DNA is all about ancestry
DNA gives you so much more than just the
places where you're from ancestry
connects you to the places in the world
where your story started using precise
geographical details and clear-cut
historical insights so it gives you the
whole story it tells you sort of the
story about yourself and about about
your family you can even trace your
ancestors journeys over
over time following how and why your
family moved from place to place it
really is fascinating to think think
about all of the things that had to
happen throughout history in order for
you to come into existence
think about all through all that time as
your ancestors and your family have been
moving from place to place and meeting
different people and and think about all
those different movements and meetings
that had to happen what are the chances
that all of that would happen to make
you you know one in a one in a trillion
probably yet it happened and to amplify
your results you can start a free trial
in ancestry and build a tree so your
ancestors become more than just a name
they've combined DNA results with over a
hundred million family trees and
billions of records to give you more
insight into your genealogy and origins
I have my ancestry kit ready to go I'm
going to send it in doesn't take very
long to get the results back I'm looking
forward to finding out I'm hoping that I
am a Viking I'm hoping I'm at least 15%
Viking that's what I figure is what I'm
rooting for go to ancestry.com slash
Matt today for 20% off your ancestry DNA
kit that's ancestry.com slash Matt for
20% off your ancestry DNA kit
ancestry.com slash Matt okay so a guy
named Steve Jacobs
as an article on the site quill 'it's
hardly a bastion of right-wing
propaganda we should say and the
headline of the article is I asked
thousands of biologists win life begins
the answer wasn't popular and in the
article he talks about his dissertation
for his PhD which which involved
abortion and as part of that research he
asked this question you asked over five
there was five thousand three hundred
something biologist when life begins
there's more to his paper than that
there's more to the article you go read
the article it's interesting it's worth
the read but I want to focus just on
this element of it for a moment this is
pretty staggering quoting now from
Jacobs he says I found that five hundred
five thousand three hundred thirty seven
biologists 96% affirmed that a human's
life begins at fertilization with two
hundred and forty four percent rejecting
that view the majority of the sample
identified as liberal eighty nine
percent
pro-choice eighty five percent and
non-religious sixty-three percent in the
case of Americans who express party
preference the majority identified as
Democrats ninety two percent so ninety
six percent of a mostly pro-abortion
non-religious Liberal Democrat
biologists sampling say that life begins
at fertilization that is about as
powerful of an answer on a question like
this that you could possibly hope to
expect because you have people saying
life begins at conception not for any
ideological reason in fact the ideology
cuts against them in guide their
ideology pushes them in the other
direction if they were to follow their
ideology they would say oh no life
doesn't begin to begin at conception the
only reason they're saying this the only
reason is because of what they know
about science they're biologists and
they know that yeah life begins at
conception it is the science is clearly
undeniable when you what occurs there at
conception
once conception occurs you have a
distinct
living bile
logical entity now I'm not a biologist
and I appreciate these biologists saying
this but I don't think you need to be a
biologist to understand this or to know
that in fact you don't really need to
understand anything about biology at all
you could have no understanding of
biology and you should stay because it's
this is this is more of a logical
conclusion than anything else we know
that just just logically we know that at
conception you've got something else
that has now come into existence despite
how its presented by the pro-abortion
side this is not an extension of the
woman's body it's not an organ or a limb
or a tumor it's just not that it is
something separate something distinct it
is an entity of some kind we know that
it is a biological entity I don't think
anyone would deny that ok well now the
question is is it alive ok
well again without even getting into the
biological specifics it would seem to me
that for any entity that exists there
are only three options it's either going
to be living in animate or dead right
those are the only there's no there's
nothing in between they're everything
that exists everything that's in this
room right now that you can see is
either living in animate or dead nothing
in between there are no in-between
categories and so we know that this desk
that I'm sitting at this is inanimate
it's a desk it's only ever gonna be this
until it decays and rots away I mean you
could chop it up and build it into
something else but it's never going to
grow on its own into something else
it doesn't breathe it doesn't consume
food it doesn't it's not it's not
developing or maturing into a you know
it's never going to it's just this is
all it is the entity in the womb is it
in
inanimate object no clearly not
is it dead well no and if it were dead
then you wouldn't need the abortion in
the first place and so that leaves only
living so it is a living biological
entity and is it human well we know that
because it was created by two human
beings and two human beings cannot mate
and create anything but another human
being they can't create a dark aura aura
or a you know spider monkey it's just
they're gonna create a another person so
that's how we know it is a living
biological human though it's nice to
have the biologists confirm this rather
obvious fact Jacobs then goes on to talk
about the backlash from an anti science
abort from the anti science abortion
enthusiast crowd that's my term that has
to be clear and he shares some of the
email he received from these loony toons
again my term not his so some of the
things he quotes some of the emails to
him is this a study funded by Trump and
the Ku Klux Klan someone else says sure
hope you you aren't an effing Christian
so what else says this is some stupid
right-to-life thing yuck I believe in
right to choice these are these are
brilliant people just a bunch a bunch of
scholars a bunch of gentlemen and
scholars over there on the pro-abortion
side someone else says the actual
purpose of this quote survey became very
clear I will do my best to disseminate
this info to make sure that none of my
naive colleagues fall into this trap
somebody else sorry this looks like it's
more of a religious survey to be used to
misinterpret by radicals to do it to
advertise about the beginning of life
and not a survey about what faculty know
about biology your advisor can contact
me someone else says I did respond to
and fill in the survey but I'm concerned
about the tenor of the questions it
seemed like a thinly disguised effort to
make biologists take a stand on the
issues that could be used to advocate
for or against abortion someone else the
relevant biological issues are obvious
and have nothing to do with when life
begins this is a nonsense position
created by the anti
abortion fanatics you have accepted the
premise of a fanatic group of lunatics
so this is this this is interesting so
you've got obviously you've got a few
emails here this is just a sampling from
it but you've got a few emails from from
semi-illiterate morons but then it's
clear that some of these messages are
from biologists who answered the survey
and I'm assuming that they answered no
life does not begin and they're kind of
revealing why they answered they're
making it clear that for them it was
ideological that they couldn't overcome
their ideological biases and so they
were afraid about well I don't I don't
know how this is gonna be used
politically so I'm just gonna pretend
that that life does not begin at
conception so I think what we see here
is 96% of biologists said life begins at
conception
the other 4% they only see only said no
because they were afraid of the
political consequences of saying yes so
really really in effect it's a hundred
percent with only with 96 more like this
96% of biologists were willing to admit
that life begins at conception the other
4% weren't willing to admit it for the
reasons they made clear here in these
emails as much as people throw around
the term anti science what you find on
the pro-abortion side is this is literal
literally anti science they don't like
what the science says so they shout and
scream and they stomp their feet and
they refuse to acknowledge it or admit
it life begins at conception there's no
way around it scientists know this it is
a it's really not even a controversial
subject it just is the only controversy
is in the political implications but
that has nothing to do with science the
science says what it says and there is
no mystery here
there really isn't you're not gonna find
the biologist as this makes it clear
you'll be hard-pressed to find
biologists who scratch their head and
say gee I don't know so then what
happens next
does the broke does the pro-abortion
side - they do they throw up their hands
and say oh we've been beaten know if
they were honest they would but they're
not honest so they don't so it's
dead either they'll just continue to
claim despite all evidence that no life
doesn't begin a conception because I
don't want it to or more likely they'll
still try for what appears to be or what
pretends to be a more nuanced and
intelligent you know a distinction
well they'll say okay yeah the being in
the womb is a human being no way around
that but it's not a person and they'll
draw this artificial distinction between
person and human I've dealt with that
distinction so many times I'm not going
to go into it in great detail here you
could find any of the number of things
I've written on the subject to see how I
deal with that what I will just briefly
say is this two points first of all if
there is a distinction between a person
and a human being can you we put it this
way can you identify if you believe in
this distinction can you identify any
other areas where you draw that
distinction so you say that a quote
fetus is a human being not a person okay
well do you do that anywhere else in
other words is is this some is this a
distinction you only specifically came
up with in order to deal with fetuses
and that's because if that's the case
that's gonna make it seem like an ad hoc
kind of thing where you just came up
with this distinction in order to get
around the obvious truth there is no
other area where we would draw this
distinction in any other context right
we would say that the term human being
and person is interchangeable it means
exactly the same thing in every other
context except in the womb where
magically mystically you try to create
this difference where it doesn't
actually exist now second point I say
that
in any other context we would admit that
a human being is a person the two are
interchangeable that's true now today
but if we look back through history that
has not always been the case think about
what we did with slaves in this country
for hundreds of years where it would
have to be admitted yes these are humans
but they're not exactly people they're
only partially people or sort of people
not quite as people he has the rest of
us my point here is that if you look
back through history there have always
been groups of people trying to claim
that other groups of people are not
people and what we find is that in every
case that effort has led to horrific
results it has always been in the
service of some evil institution that
people draw this distinction this effort
to delineate between human being and
person historically has always always
always always been in defense of evil
institutions or evil acts slavery
genocide the dehumanization of women on
and on that's a historical fact so if
you're pro-abortion maybe you look at
that trend and you see oh gee wow it
seems like there's a yeah every single
time in history when our ancestors tried
to say human not person it was because
they were trying to justify some evil
terrible thing yet Here I am saying
human not person maybe I'm justifying an
evil terrible thing - all right speaking
of anti science yesterday October 16th
was I don't know if you were aware of
this it was a holy day of observation
known as pronouns day following in the
sacred traditions of our ancestors
pronouns day provides the LGBTQ camp
with yet another opportunity it's
lecture the world about what we're
supposed to do and say and think because
the thing is that the LGBT folks they
don't have enough opportunities to do
that right they they only have this is
why they needed to come up with pronouns
day because they wanted to be able to
lecture us and and they didn't get
enough of a chance to lecture us on
International transgender day of
visibility March 31st lesbian visibility
day April 26 International Day Against
homophobia transphobia biphobia May 17th
Harvey Milk de mace 22nd pansexual and
panromantic visibility Day May 24th
Pride Month June bisexuality date
September 23rd bisexual Awareness Week
September 23rd - 2 through September
30th National Coming Out Day October
11th national LGBT Center Awareness Day
October 19th spirit day October 20th
intersex Awareness Day October 26 a
sexual Awareness Week October 23rd
transgender Day of Remembrance November
20th pansexual slash panromantic Pride
Day December 18th transgender
transsexual try solace try soul strike
try cyclists on trampolines Awareness
Day December 19th I only made one of
those up the point is that LGBT folks
apparently need a lot of days dedicated
to themselves they need a lot of days to
raise awareness about themselves and
give themselves a chance to lecture us
and that's why they had to do pronouns
day now at first blush it may seem odd
right that we have a day set aside for a
grammatical construct why not a verb day
or an adjective day or a preposition day
well I'm sure eventually we're headed in
that direction as the English language
becomes increasingly subjective eyes and
people are increasingly encouraged to
make up their own rules as they go so
maybe eventually we'll have days like
that but right now it's it's pronouns
day and there is one advantage of it is
that it might take a whole day for you
to learn all of the wild and wacky new
pronouns that have been invented out of
whole cloth in recent years it's not
just the normal ones
he/she her/him were way beyond that okay
you're stuck in the past if you think
that's the the the
those are all the pronouns or its if
it's just the traditional ones no the
ever-growing list of pronouns includes
such gobbledygook as Z her hir themself
with an ex ver exerts K X Y RS how do
you even pronounce it
exercise
self with an F but the F is in
parenthesis and none of the rest of the
world where it is exem XE m ex eggs XCX
and zelf self I made two of those up but
you can't tell which ones and that's the
point you have no idea because they're
all made up they're all nonsense none of
them have any meaning whatsoever they
are just random letters and sounds
blended into a linguistic frappe we now
live in a culture where we now live in a
culture where a sentence like this is
supposed to mean something this is a
this is a quote a real sentence now
supposedly V went to the store with /
and met zem and Z got into their car and
drove home what does that mean there's a
store there's a car there's going home
but who's going where who's doing what
who's involved
you have no idea I have no idea and I'm
the one who just came up with a sentence
because it's gibberish it doesn't mean
anything and this is the problem with
the whole idea of people claiming their
own pronouns a pronoun again is a
grammatical contract it must be deployed
according to the laws of grammar not the
individual winds of the person to whom
it refers that's not how grammar works
so if I am let's say that I got up and I
was standing on this desk could be
dangerous I could hurt my I could follow
my my head which maybe if I did follow
my head then all this stuff would start
making sense to me I don't
if I got up and I was standing on this
desk and you wanted to describe what I'm
doing you would say he is standing on
the desk now you really have to say that
because that accurately objectively
describes what's going on to say she is
standing on the desk would be wrong
because that would indicate that a
biological female is standing on the
decks desk which is incorrect if you
were to say they are standing on the
desk that's wrong too because that
indicates that more than one person is
on the desk when that is not the case if
you were to say Z is standing on the
table that would be wrong too because
that would make it seem like there's
some sort of space alien standing on the
on the desk wouldn't wouldn't no that's
not the case l so the whole point here
is to convey objective reality when you
say something like he is standing on the
desk there this is not subjective you're
not you're not describing my feelings or
my emotions so if I'm standing on the
desk while feeling like a woman whatever
that means then you could say something
like he is standing on a man who feels
like a woman is standing on a desk or
it's something like that would work but
my own personal feelings doesn't affect
how you grammatically convey what's
happening now in a similar way if I was
standing on the desk and I were to tell
you that my preferred preposition is off
if I were to tell you I don't like the
preposition on I prefer off that's what
that's my personal property preposition
okay fine you know I like the word or
not off whatever that means
but it still would be nonsensical for
you to go and tell someone he's standing
off the table because I'm not I'm on it
not off of it
and that's what this comes down to
prepositions nouns verbs and pronouns
are meant to convey objective facts and
reality if they're not going to perform
that function then they no longer
perform any function at all and
meaningful useful words have been
reduced to impotent nonsense but
shouldn't we just be polite and use
somebody's preferred pronoun just to you
know make them feel better shouldn't we
do that the answer is no okay
no we don't I'll tell you why first
because you don't generally call
somebody a pronoun when you're speaking
to them so this whole thing about how
it's about it's about being polite and
respected it's it's irrelevant most of
the time anyway because you're not if if
I'm in the room and you're talking to me
you're not gonna say he or him you're
gonna talk directly to me you're gonna
use my name and my name can be whatever
I want it to be so if you yes your name
is totally subjective its arbitrary your
name could be anything so whatever you
say your name is I'll call you that well
it's your name it could be anything so
if you're a man and you say you want
your name to be Sally then I'll call you
Sally if you're if you're a woman you
want your name to be Fred you say your
name is Fred I'll call you Fred whatever
you say your name is you say your name
is Higley boo I'll call you hey gali boo
I mean what it doesn't matter it's your
name it can be anything but pronouns are
more objective than that and they're
also more distant
so you're usually called by a pronoun
when you're not physically present for
the discussion so when someone insists
on a preferred pronoun what he's trying
to do is he's trying to prevent you from
using proper grammar in relation to him
when he's not even in the room with you
so he's essentially saying whenever you
refer to me even if I'm ten thousand
miles away you must abandon the rules of
grammar and pare it whatever nonsensical
gibberish I assigned to you that's not
only arrogant it's not only absurd it's
arrogant
arrogant and absurd absurd an area tea
that's what it is how are you why would
you even attempt to control the language
used well you're not even there how
could it possibly affect you then the
second point of course is that using an
incorrect pronoun is alive it's
dishonest you know if I say she in
reference to a man I am conveying an
untruth and I am doing so deliberately
and so that is a lie it might be alive
with good intentions it may feel it
might be a lie meant to avoid conflict
or whatever but it's still a lie and I
think it's wrong to lie but then okay
but doesn't grammar evolve over time
maybe this is just the evolution of
grammar
well yeah grammar and language does
evolve over time but it evolves
according to a coherent set of rules and
standards in fact that is what evolves
is the rules and standards can evolve
but the point is that they remain rules
and standards which means that they have
to remain objective not objective and
they're in the in in in in a sense of
being immutable and unchangeable but
objective and in that they're the same
for everybody and that's not what we're
talking about here we're talking about
people making up their own rules
individually according to their own
feelings and desires
that's not evolution that's devolution
that's collapse that is the collapse of
language language is being destroyed
here not it's not changing it's not
being modified or evolved it is being
destroyed because if we don't have that
agreed set of standards and rules that
are say the same for everybody when it
comes to language then we can't
communicate anymore besides and here's
really the main thing we aren't talking
merely about changes in language that's
not what we're talking about now if we
all decided decided to start using the
word zem xcm however it's pronounced
just say Sam I don't know how it's
pronounced
it can be pronounced any way you want I
guess that's the point
so uh this is M is a made-up pronoun
well if we all if we all decided that
you know what we're gonna start using
the the words M instead of him okay we
can do that I think it's a little weird
it's kind of dr.seuss II uh
in in my opinion but the word him
doesn't always have to be him if you go
somewhere else in the world they don't
have the word him they have a different
word for it different languages have
their own word for him and sometimes
those those words change okay fine but
the LGBTQ lobby they aren't asking us to
exchange one word for another rather the
lobby is asked demanding actually that
we pretend to believe in an entire new
category of human existence Zen is not a
new word for him Zen is supposed to be a
completely separate sort of person
neither her nor him but nobody could
even begin to explain what a ZEM is
exactly and how it differs from a her or
him they only say well some people
identify as M okay identify as what what
is that what does it mean to be as M how
did you first discover that you were as
M how does it what is it what is it
what's the process that you went through
to to discover the the that you are as M
describe the experience of discovering
that your as M what does as M do
differently what are the biological
markers of as M and how does this M
differ from Azzurro or as ur or serve in
more a Dabba Dabba doodle film or
whatever how do how does any distinguish
between all these different things but
nobody can
no one can provide any coherent answer
for any of this just just as I have
pointed out many many many times and
I'll continue to point out that nobody
can even explain or describe what it
actually means for a man to identify as
a woman manses identify as a woman what
do you mean what exactly do you mean by
that can't explain it what is a woman
can't explain it I've been asking that
question for eight months no one has
offered an answer not one person I mean
not not one leftist I should say
so this is all nonsense it doesn't mean
anything and yet we are supposed to
timidly cooperate as they mutilate our
language and make nonsense out of
everything and I'm just not going to do
that I'm I'm not gonna cooperate with
that right because why should I
no no I'm not good no that's my answer
no okay
one other thing before we get to emails
heartwarming video to play for you today
things have been a little too serious so
let's let's lighten the mood visit those
extinction rebellion idiots the climate
activists who have been stopping traffic
all over the Western world
they've especially been wreaking havoc
in over in the UK and here's a video
from based on the accents it looks like
this is in London its extinction
rebellion climate activists climate
alarmists who are standing on the top of
a train preventing a whole group of
people from getting to their jobs so
they can feed their families and here's
how that went
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay so he's dragged off the train there
and beaten by a crowd
I would never condone violence however
actually there's not however period end
of a sentence next sentence when you
prevent an entire crowd of people from
getting to their jobs to feed their
families you are going to make them
angry and justifiably so and so whatever
happens next is your fault so I am going
to have zero sympathy for you
zero that is 100% your fault it's all on
you totally you have no right to be
doing that and it just boggles my mind
that these people these climate
alarmists are allowed to continue doing
this how is how are the police not
showing up immediately with bus with
buses and just arresting all of these
idiots you can't do this you can't just
stop traffic stop that's you have no
that's not First Amendment rights there
that's you have no right to do that no
right and if the police aren't going to
step in immediately and just arrest
everybody doing it which is what they
should be doing then the crowd might get
very angry and might take matters into
their own hands and that's on you I know
no sane person is gonna feel remotely
sorry for you and by the way they're
taking public transportation you [ __ ]
these are a whole group of people trying
to get on the same mode of
transportation isn't that what you want
isn't that the whole thing you want
people isn't that the most
environmentally environmentally friendly
way of traveling and commuting that's
what they're trying to do when you're
stopping them okay that was supposed to
be a pick-me-up
but it got a little little these people
just the arrogance of it the arrogance
and it makes it even worse that all of
these climate alarmists or who are doing
these protests if we can even call it
protests you know you know none of them
have jobs they it's easy for them
because they're living off their they're
either living off the government or
they're living off of their parents or
both so it's very easy for them to step
in and prevent other people from getting
for them to their jobs and they could
say oh there's more important things
than getting to your job well easy for
you to say you unemployed
non-contributing zero it's easy for you
to say you're going home to sit on your
beanbag chair while your mom makes you
hot pockets that's easy for you to say
the rest of us have families that we
have to take care of I know that concept
is foreign to you okay let's go to
emails Matt well show at gmail.com says
from Kel this is from Kelly says I know
how much the left speaks of men and
women being the same and there should
never be an excuse for men to try to
differentiate between this two so I
asked should women be able to use PMSing
as an excuse for being in a bad mood I
feel like this is a great argument that
clearly women are different than men I
tried to tell my wife this and she
almost strangled me at the dinner table
you said it at the dinner table now that
is bold just want to know your thoughts
thanks for being a great voice of my
generation keep up the excellent work
Kelly you call me a great voice of our
generation and then you try to get me
killed
so there seems to be a contradiction
there I am NOT going to fall into that
trap and besides as we have already been
through today this is the year 2019
there's no reason why a man can't PMS
okay so you you are your entire premise
is transphobic
from Steve says hi Matt thanks for the
great show truly appreciate the humor
insight and intellectual honesty you
bring to the table during your email
segment yesterday show I was I was
startled when I heard you mentioned your
daughter's name your new daughter's name
my wife and I have seven kids and our
only daughter [ __ ] oh you have six six
boys huh I don't know how you do it hi
we got two boys and honestly when I hear
people that have four five six boys how
is your house still standing is it or
you at this point have you just given up
and you're living out you're just living
in the woods somewhere under the open
sky because I don't honestly I don't how
does your house server how does anything
survive with that many boys running
around god bless you anyway
our daughter shares the same name Emma
grace although it sounds like you
decided to separate the two and go with
Emma grace so he's got Emma Grace as one
word we had similar discussions and
concerns as you and opted for the
spelling here we knew we wanted to be
one word and chose to capitalize the G
even though it's in the middle of the
name otherwise would look tat he might
you might try to pronounce it as M
Grassi or something like that
and yes when we would say her name to
someone we would always follow up by
saying capital G no space so a little
extra work but never a big issue we
always thought it was a beautiful
sounding name and still do to this day
although in an odd footnote our daughter
22 now has recently dropped the grace
part and just goes by Emma thanks and
best wishes to you in your family well
your odd footnote at the end that may
that's the whole point that makes my
entire point you go through all of this
work for 20 years to explain her name to
people you put on all that blood sweat
and tears clarifying her name constantly
and then the moment she gets a chance
she just cuts her name in half and
throws out all the work you did it's a
tragedy and that was one of my concerns
with my wife that I raised in an
argument that I ended up being right
about I don't know if you caught that
part I was right
my wife was wrong I was right but that
was one of my concerns as I figured
people are just gonna call her Emma
anyway and that's probably what she's
gonna do for the for the sake of being
just because it
easier and it all of our work will be
for nothing
so that is that's a tragedy my
condolences to you from Adam says well
see you this is from I'll do that one
tomorrow
this one's from Aaron says earlier this
week you attempted to place Columbus in
historical context in which he lived by
claiming that by our modern standards
everyone board before nineteen seventy
would be morally unacceptable to us
specifically the idea is that land
conquest through violence and racism are
immoral are very modern notions even if
that's true how can you claim to believe
in the objective truth of Christianity
while still maintaining the historical
figures aren't responsible for the evils
they've committed if those evils were
universally accepted back then Christ
revealed the fullness of truth in 33 AD
the Bible Canon was complete in the
fifth century so Columbus and all of the
European conquerors would have had full
access to the Gospels before they set
sail they had the same gospel we do they
had no excuse for taking land by force
or for treating those with different
skin as subhuman mat without even
realizing it by attempting to
contextualize their actions you are
becoming an apologist for moral
relativism okay a few things here first
of all you bring up the Bible the Bible
does not explicitly condemn invasion and
conquest or racism in fact in the Old
Testament well you could make an
argument for racism there are some lines
especially in epistles there is no Jew
or Greek man or woman in Christ you know
that sort of thing which which is a
condemnation of racism but here's my
point you take in the Old Testament in
fact it would seem to explicitly condone
invasion and conquest even command it at
various different points now I'm not
actually I'm not saying that invasion
and conquest is actually consistent with
biblical teaching I'm not saying that
slavery and racism is consistent with
biblical teaching I'm just saying that
on first reading it may not have been
immediately obvious to people a long
time ago that the Bible forbids
because it doesn't explicitly forbid it
it doesn't come out at any point and say
in very clear terms stop doing this
stuff now we get to those prohibitions
in a more roundabout way for example
that verse from Paul that I just
paraphrased we today now see that as a
something that speaks very much to the
issues of slavery and racism and I think
it does but my point is just that for a
long time that's not how people read it
and that's just the reality so the fact
that the Bible can and must complete has
I think little bearing on this
discussion considering it just because
it doesn't speak very directly to these
issues it took people a while to see it
for what I believe it it is second moral
relativism would be if I said that it
actually wasn't wrong for our ancestors
to go and enslave and kill and do all
that kind of stuff I specifically did
not say that in fact I said the opposite
I said that it is objective I'm pretty
sure I said multiple times it obviously
was objectively wrong for them to do
those things just as wrong then as it is
now the question though is not one of
the objective moral rightness or
wrongness of the act the the question is
one of moral culpability and this
distinction between the the objective
moral rightness and or wrongness of an
act and the moral culpability of the
person who performs the act is very very
important for us to understand not just
for the context of this discussion but
in any discussion we need to be able to
understand this and I find that a lot of
people for some reason this is a
distinction that that is lost on a lot
of people I'm not sure why so for
example if a crazy person murders
somebody obviously murder was wrong
murder wasn't suddenly okay because a
crazy person did it the act was just as
wrong for him as it would be for me but
he was
personally culpable than I would be
because of his mental state you see and
that was my point about slavery not that
slave owners 500 years ago were crazy
but that they had less moral culpability
all that time ago then I then I would
have today if I went and bought a slave
the act itself is just as wrong in both
cases but our ancestors for thousands of
years lived in a world where slavery was
an accepted institution everywhere
across the planet it just it's just what
people did it's how it's how the world
works for the 15th time that doesn't
mean that it was actually right it just
it just it is relevant it has it bears
on their personal culpability for doing
it it just really didn't occur to a lot
of people for a long time that there was
anything in principle wrong with slavery
in the 15th century there weren't a lot
of abolitionists were running around and
they're especially weren't a lot in the
year 500 BC and further in time that you
go it's there's even you're gonna find
that even less and less so why didn't it
why didn't it occur so that many people
that slavery was wrong well because
apparently the wrongness of slavery is
not in an eight moral insight it's not
something that just comes naturally to
people
apparently it feels innate for us
because we were raised in a society that
completely condemns it and rightfully so
but clearly if you if you look at this
from an anthropological perspective it's
clear that this is not in a innate
insight this is more of something that
came about through progress through
moral progress we haven't morally
progressed in every area in recent eyes
but we well we have morally progressed
in some areas especially where it
pertains to slavery racism that kind of
thing
humanity had to over thousands of years
progress to a point where the wrongness
of slavery became clear and there were
philosophical developments that had to
happen to make that possible such as the
formulation of the doctor
of universal human rights like I said a
long time ago nobody thought of that it
just it's not something that people
thought of it's not a concept that was
really available to them and there was
scientific advancement such as the
revelation that we are all one species
with only very small biological
variances between us that also was not
obvious to people a long time ago
2,000 years ago the idea that you live
in your tribe or in your province your
town with your people the idea that
people thousand miles away are exactly
equal to you in every respect that just
that would have seemed nonsensical to
everybody back then so again all this
stuff is obvious to us now thank God but
it wasn't obvious to our ancestors these
are inside and this is another thing
that our ancestors had to the we we
didn't earn these insights we didn't we
did we didn't come up with any of this
you know we're not the abolitionists we
came along after the abolition and we're
not the civil rights activists we came
along most of us watching this came
along I know I did after all of that and
so we inherited a society were certain
moral truths seemed to us to be
self-evident but that society was built
over a long period of time and a lot was
went into building that and there was a
lot of literal blood sweat and tears
that went into it and I think it is it
is the height of snobbery for us to come
along and treat all of this like it's so
perfectly obvious and to look down our
nose on all of our ancestors
who hadn't quite figured it out when we
didn't figure it out either and so
that's my only point it is a mitigating
circumstance and so yes well I would say
that something like slavery always evil
but the people who engaged in it five
hundred years ago a thousand years ago
two thousand years ago they simply do
not have the same moral guilt that you
and I would for all the reasons that
I've tried to explain okay
oh and last thing I'll say is like I
said when we talked about this you
either have to agree with me on this or
what's the implication of disagreeing
with me the implication it because
what's the only other option either I am
right about this and there's in the
moral guilt as mitigated or almost
everybody who existed throughout history
up until very recently they were all
about just under complete scumbags with
almost no redeeming moral qualities and
that you talk about a simplistic way of
looking at the world not only that but a
very reductive insulting way of looking
at the world ie that know that I'm not
willing to look at the world like that
or to look at our ancestors like that
and I also think it's just factually
incorrect ok we'll leave it there thanks
everybody for watching Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey
everybody its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show you know some people
are depressed because the American
Republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moon has turned
to blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over the Andrew Clavin show
and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]